du foot au vélo week-end de découverte à
montigny le bretonneux avec une météo
plutôt clémente on va regarder ce sujet
d'alice gastines on en reparle juste
après avec deux nouveaux invités et
sachez qu'il y avait jusqu'à vingt mille
participants sur ce rendez vous
j'ai suivi un groupe sur le 25 km sur
route et c'était assez agréable voilà
avec ipsl et non j'étais pas seule il y
avait la petite derrière dans la
carriole c'est un peu plus lourd dans
les côtes
huit parcours au choix allant de 15 à
105 kilomètres pour découvrir le
cyclotourisme dans la vallée de
chevreuse une initiative du vélo club de
montigny le plus gros deal de france
avec plus de 400 licenciés cette année
on a battu notre record de l'an dernier
avec 2002 participants à l'ensemble des
randonnées qui était proposé
c'est bien d'aider un mot de l'église
enfin le bout de chou est intéressant
c'est sympa
pour tout pour faire du vélo un faux pas
qui est trop de monde mais cela est dû
mon nom au live du monde mais moment
fait à coude et pour les passants ont
passé un autre temps fort de
l'association la monty cyclo au mois de
juin tout au long de l'année le club
organise des sorties à la journée ou sur
plusieurs jours en vélo de route ou en
vtt dès l'âge de 13 ans
et pour parler de cette fête du vélo il
y avait 2000 participants et non pas
vingt mille ce plateau ce moment je me
suis un petit peu emballé sur 2000
plateau alain léveillé président de la
section cyclotourisme du club de
montigny et denis renier trésorier de la
section vtt de montigny-le-bretonneux
bonsoir à vous deux
tout d'abord quel est l'objectif de la
fête du vélo c'est de montrer que l'on
peut faire du vélo autrement
choisi alain
badiou l'objectif c'est déjà de feu
effectivement de votre permettre un
maximum de gens de là la vie de
nouvelles et de la commune de montigny
de participer à une activité de loisir
qu'est le vélo est de leur faire
découvrir des sentiers qu'ils
connaissent pas ou d où des déroutes
qu'il n'oserait peut-être pas prendre
seul c'est aussi à
la volonté de barrer de répondre aux
souhaits de nos fédérations étant donné
que nous sommes un club
qui est le premier club d'île de france
en matière de vélo puisque ont réuni 450
adhérents les sur les deux sections donc
est tout à fait normal qu'on propose une
organisation ouverte à tous les clubs
d'île de france qui eux mêmes de leur
côté nous proposent leurs propres rangs
rallye ou ordonner et justement je crois
que cette année vous avez battu votre
record d'affluence sur la fête du vélo
côté donc vététistes on a on a explosé
les compteurs avec mille quatre cent
cinquante participants sur les réunit
sur les quatre circuits donc ont proposé
un cercle famille de 16 km il y avait un
circuit de 35 un circuit de 50 et puis
pour les plus costauds un circuit de 60
donc dans la vallée de chevreuse
et voilà donc ça s'est assez bien
déroulé il a fait beau et ça c'est
l'essentiel les gens se sont amusés se
sont régalés c'est les retours qu'on a
déjà un peu par par le biais d'internet
et ça c'est ce qu'on veut c'est notre
récompense pensée investi tout le long
de l'année et surtout donc
particulièrement sur ce week end on a eu
25 bénévoles pour nous le samedi pour le
balisage et une cinquantaine au dimanche
donc de 6h30 du matin jusqu'à les
derniers se rentrer à 16 heures donc
voilà c'est quand même les grosses
journées et donc ça nous notre
récompense c'est d'avoir fait plaisir à
tous tout ce joli monde et les
participants justement de ce rendez vous
annuel ce sont des amoureux de la
c'est des vététistes aguerris on a de
tout c'est pour ça on propose de tout
donc ans
on en partenariat avec la mairie de
montigny lohan f nous aide énormément
parce que si on peut proposer ce nouveau
circuit c'est grâce à lodève qui nous
autorise
l'accès dans l'est dans les bois et donc
on a un gros partenariat avec e on
travaille constamment avec eux puisque
s'il ya certaines zones ou que l'on doit
respecter on ne peut pas passer grâce à
eux on arrive à proposer aux gens de
beaux parcours et donc ça va des dirait
des familles sur ce parcours de qui vont
chez pas je dirais qu'il ya des enfants
qui ont cinq six ans 7 ans jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à a plus d'âge donc donc
c'est vraiment ouvert à tout le monde et
pour revenir un petit peu dans
l'actualité eu les jeux olympiques cet
été une belle médaille d'or de julie
bresset ge est ce que justement il ya eu
un effet j'ai eu un effet médailles d'or
et les jeunes arrivent et disent je veux
faire du vélo on a on a énormément de
demandes malheureusement on est passé de
bénévoles est donc cette année
on a bouclé notre on a bouclé notre
école vtt on a déjà 60 enfants et on
peut plus en prendre plus donc oui le
vélo prend une ampleur énorme et on le
voit tous les ans a grossi de plus en
plus malheureusement on manque de
bénévoles donc appel aux bénévoles ça
s'appelle aux bénévoles oui pour rester
dans l'actualité justement est ce qu'il
ya un effet dû au dopage d'érosion
justement ou de perte des valeurs est-ce
que vous le ressentez aussi ça non non
non parce que dans le vtt je parle pour
le vtt on le ressent moins et on essaie
d'inculquer aux enfants
dès l'école donc de tout ce jeu tous que
ce que peut apporter le vélo et puis on
parle aussi du dopage mais dans
communément nous c'est non non pas que
vous pouvez en parler on en débat c'est
pareil un cyclo touriste est pareil
puisque principes de notre activité
c'est qu'il ya pas de compétition pas de
classement donc
le je pense que le cyclisme de
compétition a beaucoup plus les clubs de
compétition ont beaucoup plus souffert
de des affaires de dopage que notre
activité qui au contraire est une
activité ouverte à tous et où c'est
plutôt des sports santé donc c'est un
peu l'objectif donc l'épicé
cyclotourisme donc en même temps faire
un peu de tourisme donc ya pas que le
monde professionnel porte toujours les
clubs amateurs derrière ça retombe
toujours sur le fil à l'image du vélo
globalement là puisqu'on parle du vélo
comme on vous le vivez ce genre de
d'événements par exemple lance armstrong
qui est déchu de tous ses titres
nous a pas surpris non
vous voyez le personnage vous dites
quand même il faut pouvoir les faire
tous et ce nombre de kilomètres il était
toujours au dessus du lot après oui
c'est vrai que
mais bon moi je vois ça quand même un
peu avec un peu de recul
et puis l'impact du dopage et peut-être
moindre aussi dans vtt parce qu'on dit
souvent que le vtt un peu une discipline
à part dans le vélo du coup les valeurs
sont peut-être un petit peu différente
et puis nous on est surtout randonneurs
donc voilà on cherche pas là on ne
cherche pas la performance on chance à
faire plaisir voilà elle est à découvrir
des deux centièmes ce qu'on peut dire
aussi que c'est qu'on allait les
contre-exemples décevant par rapport au
dopage c'est que hier il y avait notre
plus nos plus anciens pratiquants ont
participé à la randonnée cyclotouriste
avait quand même eu deux plaintes et un
couple marié femme qui avait cent
soixante trois ans à eux deux et vous
pouvez nous assurer qu'ils n'ont rien
pris et je pense et n'ont rien pris et
le et l'homme est un dock et fait partie
de l'amicale des cyclos cardiaque parce
que il a été gardien de but même effet
et et yabo au nabot ou dans nos
adhérents des gens qui viennent au vélo
après les accidents cardiaques parce que
ses conseillés par leur cardiologue quel
est le prochain rendez vous justement
dans l'actualité très rapide l'année
pour le club nous là on va on a
challenge en maréchal on va accueillir
les nouveaux donc un petit challenge où
on met un nouveau est un ancien et puis
là c'est une petite compétition dans le
club comme ça ça permet de bien je
dirais resserrer les liens entre les
nouveaux et les anciens et de créer je
dirais la mayonnaise qui fait que le
club vit bien puisque nous aussi on est
un des hauts niveaux vtt on est un des
plus gros clubs donc est ce qui permet
un engouement et et puis après il va ya
voir l'hiver la saison va un peu se
finir et on commencera l'année prochaine
avec des belles randos au printemps très
bien merci beaucoup à vous d'être venu
sur le plateau du 7-8 merci à vous merci
merci également anthony pour cette page
sports et puis juste un mot pour
compléter un mot de baseball est les
playoffs front national une se
poursuivre pour l'équipe de montigny le
bretonneux les cougars recevait dimanche
les indians de boé-bon-encontre deux
matchs étaient au programme à l'arrivée
une seule victoire 9 3 le matin 1 à 5
l'après midi seulement en face aux
représentants du lot et garonne de
résultat qui laisse toujours la
possibilité à montigny d'accéder aux
finales des 6 et 7 octobre et
d'envisager ainsi la montée en division
élite un retour parmi l'élite pour les
cougars le déplacement à vauréal la
semaine prochaine ne devrait pas poser
de problème l'équipe du val d'oise n'a
compté aucune victoire en six rencontres
de playoffs en revanche il faudra
s'imposer pour finir face à dunkerque
concurrents directs pour cette deuxième
place synonyme de finale les deux clubs
dunkerque montini ils sont aujourd'hui à
égalité de points en troisième position
au classement voilà merci donc anthony
on vous retrouve à lundi prochain pour
le sport